I think we just release a whole episode on coaches. I think there should be a catch episode You know what folks screw it. We got six more minutes of God and can we talk about sleeper sofas? Welcome to 80 SP the podcast episode 177 recorded on March 6, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we hear from Bryce the epic saga of his past coach purchases. All right. We're recording now, but hey, well, your voice is loud.
我想我们刚发布了一整集关于教练的内容。我觉得应该有一集关于沙发的。你知道吗，各位，去他的。我们还有六分钟的时间，我们能聊聊沙发床吗？欢迎收听第177集 80 SP播客，录制于2024年3月6日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，我们将从Bryce那里听到他过去购买沙发的史诗级故事。好了，我们现在开始录音了，嘿，你的声音太大了。
Let's do a little game check here. You're thinking about? We got the Zoom H6, folks. We got to turn this down because my voice is too crispy. Say something a little game check here. You're thinking about... We got the Zoom H6 folks. We got to turn this down because my voice is too crispy. Say something into the mic, Bryce. Shut up and listen to me. Alright. That's probably not going in the podcast
我们来做个简单的音量检查。你在想什么？我们有Zoom H6，各位。我们得调低一点，因为我的声音太刺耳了。对着麦克风说点什么，Bryce。闭嘴听我说。好吧，那段大概不会放进播客里。
because as a Canadian, we like to spread kindness in the world. Alright. That was too loud. We are here in Bryce's apartment. Have we ever recorded in either of our apartments? We have not.
因为作为加拿大人，我们喜欢在世界上传播善意。好吧，那太吵了。我们现在在Bryce的公寓里。我们以前在彼此的公寓里录过音吗？没有。
And I got to tell you, probably the acoustics are fantastic in this apartment because Bryce has got a lot of fluffy pillows, a lot of couch real estate. He's got twice as much couch real estate. Have we done the couch story on the podcast? No. You know what? I would say typically the listener doesn't care. But you know what?
我得告诉你，这个公寓的音响效果可能非常棒，因为Bryce有很多蓬松的枕头，还有很大的沙发空间。他的沙发空间是平时的两倍。我们在播客里讲过沙发的故事吗？没有。你知道吗？我想通常听众并不关心。但你知道吗？
I'm actually kind of interested at this moment, which is rare. You must have heard this story. Well, give us a little quick jog of the memory. Hi, I'm only going to tell this story if you promise not to turn exit. I don't want to know. only going to tell this story if you promise not to 10x it i promise to not 10x all of it but hey if it's a good story i'll leave the whole thing in give me a little time estimate they're all good stories um so uh this is the second couch i have a couch guy this is the second couch that i've had this couch guy i'm gonna interrupt you right there folks so i've been staying at bryce's apartment it's uh what is it wednesday afternoon i got here tuesday midday so i've been here for about 24 hours that's bryce eating an
我现在其实有点感兴趣，这很少见。你一定听过这个故事。好吧，给我们简单回忆一下。嘿，我只会在你保证不夸大其词的情况下讲这个故事。我不想知道。我只会在你保证不夸大其词的情况下讲这个故事。我保证不夸大其词，但嘿，如果是个好故事，我会把它完整保留下来。给我一个时间估计，它们都是好故事。嗯，这是我买的第二个沙发，我有一个专门的沙发商，这是我从这个沙发商那里买的第二个沙发。我得打断你一下，各位，我一直住在Bryce的公寓里，现在是周三下午，我周二中午到的，所以我在这里待了大约24小时。那是Bryce在吃一个
apple definitely the mics picked that up and bryce is actually he's got a very nice apartment very nice apartment i will say bryce will maintain that his view is better than mine It is not I have one of the best views in Toronto Yes, one of the best views in Toronto It's still worse than a bad view in New York But we actually have a good view in New York There is No Dude, when you look out your window
苹果，麦克风肯定录进去了。Bryce的公寓确实非常好，非常好的公寓。我会说Bryce会坚持认为他的视野比我的好。其实并没有，我在多伦多拥有最好的视野之一。是的，多伦多最好的视野之一。它仍然比纽约最差的视野还要差。但我们在纽约其实有很好的视野。没有，伙计，当你看向窗外时
You know what you see? I see the CN Tower You see Toronto I see America You can see America And that's the thing I live so high up in the Canadians
你知道你看到了什么吗？我看到了加拿大国家电视塔。你看到了多伦多。我看到了美国。你可以看到美国。这就是重点，我住得很高，在加拿大人
Get that right Connor When Connor was listing The great things That was for you That was for you The great things That you see
把这点搞清楚，Connor。当Connor列举那些伟大的事物时，那是给你的。那是给你的。那些伟大的事物
From his apartment in Toronto That was for you The CN Tower And then Oh yeah America Yeah you can see America Because if we roll a tape back You were about to say that because it's
从他在多伦多的公寓里看到的。那是给你的。加拿大国家电视塔。然后，哦，对了，美国。是的，你可以看到美国。因为如果我们倒带的话，你本来要说那个，因为那是
just canada and so then i added america in there anyways my point being i have a nicer view but bryce has a much he has a much nicer apartment he's got i was i said they were gold fixtures bryce immediately corrected me he said they're brass it's very nice though and brass yeah yeah brush brass brass there's a little tongue twister. Brushed brass. It's very nice. And, yeah, he's got the walnut credenza. He's got the walnut coffee table.
只是加拿大，所以我加了美国进去。总之，我的意思是我的视野更好，但Bryce的公寓要好得多。他有，我刚才说那是金色的固定装置，Bryce立刻纠正了我，他说那是黄铜的。不过确实很漂亮，黄铜，是的，是的，拉丝黄铜，黄铜。这是一个小绕口令。拉丝黄铜。非常漂亮。而且，是的，他有胡桃木餐具柜。他有胡桃木咖啡桌。
I was told that I would be killed if I put anything on the walnut credenza. And he also gave me the backstory. I told Connor, you can put your stuff on the walnut coffee table, but I will kill you if you put anything on the credenza. Which I appreciate. I appreciate the sort of upfront communication. He could have just murdered me without that information. The walnut coffee table is my oldest piece of furniture, and I do love it dearly, but it's not going to, I think, make it to the next department. But the credenza is much more of a unique piece and quite fancy and Spanish.
我被告知如果我在胡桃木餐具柜上放任何东西，我会被杀掉。他也给了我背景故事。我告诉Connor，你可以把东西放在胡桃木咖啡桌上，但如果你在餐具柜上放任何东西，我会杀了你。我很欣赏这一点。我很欣赏这种直截了当的沟通。他本可以不告诉我这些就直接杀了我。胡桃木咖啡桌是我最古老的家具，我非常爱它，但我认为它不会带到下一个公寓了。但餐具柜是一件更独特、相当精致且是西班牙风格的。
And it's not Spanish walnut. We went over this yesterday. It's not Spanish walnut. It's like, I think it's- You said it was Brazilian walnut. Somewhere in South, somewhere in the Americas, walnut. It may be American walnut, but it's made by people in Spain or Portugal. somewhere in south somewhere in the americas walnut it may be american walnut but it's made
而且它不是西班牙胡桃木。我们昨天讨论过这个。它不是西班牙胡桃木。我想它是——你说它是巴西胡桃木。在南方某处，在美洲某处的胡桃木。它可能是美国胡桃木，但它是西班牙或葡萄牙人制造的。在南方某处，在美洲某处的胡桃木。它可能是美国胡桃木，但它是
by people in spain or portugal i don't remember the iberian peninsula though all right at this point our listeners probably don't care anymore but my point here was that bryce i actually can't remember what you were saying that made me want to interrupt you but i was telling my couch story yeah but you said something specifically where i did want to comment that Bryce has a very nice place. And it is really the fixtures, you know. It's turning the tap on in the bathroom. It's a lovely experience, folks. It makes me...
西班牙或葡萄牙人制造的。我不记得伊比利亚半岛了。好吧，此时此刻我们的听众可能已经不在乎了，但我的重点是，Bryce，我其实不记得你说了什么让我想要打断你，但我当时在讲我的沙发故事。是的，但你说了些特别的话，我确实想评论一下Bryce的住处非常好。确实是那些固定装置，你知道。在浴室里打开水龙头，那是一种美妙的体验，各位。它让我……
The heated bathroom floors. Yeah, that's also... I mean, that's nothing special. I mean, I've been in a few places that have that. I've never owned a place or rented a place that has that. But I will say it's just something I didn't realize in actually my whole life. I'm 33 now, folks. I've never lived in a place that wasn't kind of, it didn't feel like it had kind of like, you know, not top class like the people that constructed it.
加热的浴室地板。是的，那也是……我的意思是，那没什么特别的。我的意思是，我去过一些有那种设施的地方。我从来没有拥有或租过有那种设施的地方。但我得说，这是我一生中从未意识到的事情。我现在33岁了，各位。我从来没有住过一个感觉不是那种，你知道，不是那种建造它的人所带来的顶级品质的地方。
It kind of feels like they cut corners. I feel like probably a lot of people listening have this shared experience where, you know, little things in the apartment, things aren't screwed in completely well, or they kind of jiggle, or blah, blah, blah, or, you know, the water leaks here and there. Whereas it feels like Bryce's place, they got everything tightened, tightened real tight.
感觉他们好像偷工减料了。我觉得很多听众可能有这种共同的经历，你知道，公寓里的小东西，东西没有完全拧紧，或者它们有点晃动，或者诸如此类，或者，你知道，水在这里或那里漏水。而Bryce的地方感觉他们把一切都拧紧了，拧得非常紧。
This is a universal... Is this a facade? There is no price point at which like Bryce's place. They got everything tightened, tightened real tight. This is a universal. There is no price point at which you do not notice mistakes that were made in the place that you live. I could.
这是一个普遍的……这是一个假象吗？没有任何价位能像Bryce的地方那样。他们把一切都拧紧了，拧得非常紧。这是一个普遍现象。没有任何价位是你不会注意到你所居住的地方所犯的错误的。我可以。
So I just haven't picked up on the ones in your place? I could show you half. I mean, the ones here are not as bad as in, you
所以我只是没发现你住处的问题？我可以给你看一半。我的意思是，这里的问题不像我住过的其他地方那么严重。但我可以给你看一半那些烦人的小事，你知道，这个地方周围的事情。好吧，总之，我只是说当我打开水龙头时，
know, other places I've lived. But I could show you half of those annoying little things, you know things around this place. Okay. Well, anyways, I'm just saying that when I turned the tap on,
我确实心想，我希望我住的下一个地方也有这样的水龙头。不过你在浴室里得小心，因为热水龙头出来的水温只有一个，那就是烫伤。而且它是那种烦人的有两个把手的，如果你试图混合冷热水，你基本上总是只能得到冷水，或者像你必须微调才能得到不是烫得要命或者完全冰冷的水。
I did think to myself, I would like some taps like this in my next place that I live in. You do have to be careful in the bathroom, though, because the hot water tap comes in one temperature, which is scalding. And it's one of those annoying ones where it's got two um uh two handles and um if you try to mix the water um the hot and the cold water you pretty much always just get cold and on like you have to like micro adjust to get like water
这就像我们不需要两个旋钮，一个旋钮就够了。这是真的，这是一个非常糟糕的设计。这和我读过的一本书《追求优雅》中让我愤怒的事情是一样的，它谈到了很多事情，包括杰克·波洛克的画作的分形本质等等。但他们指出的其中一件事是门，比如你进入时推一侧，然后离开时拉。但大多数这些门，它们两边都有把手。所以每次你伸手去拿把手时，你的自然倾向就是拉，因为它是这样设计的。
that is not like scalding hot or just like completely cold it's like we didn't need two knobs for this one knob would have been fine this is true it's a very poor design it's the same thing that infuriates me ever i read a book once called the pursuit of elegance and it talks about many things including like the fractal nature of jack Pollock's paintings and whatnot. But one of the things they point out is that doors, like doors that, you know, you enter and you push one way and then when you exit, you pull. But most of these doors, they have handles on both sides. And so every single time your natural inclination when you reach for a handle is to pull because that's what it's designed for.
所以为什么会有任何门两边都有把手，除非它是双向的？如果它是双向的，你只能通过拉来离开，通过推来进入，你不应该有把手。我任何时候抓或扭把手或拉东西，而你必须推它，这都会让我发疯，仅仅因为我读过那本书，然后它被指出来了，这是那种一旦被指出来，就会让我抓狂的事情。我的意思是，冷热两个水龙头不是世界末日，不是必要的，但不是世界末日，但门，你会喜欢那扇门，它与门框不匹配，你会注意到你需要，这是一个很棒的安全功能，如果你有我公寓的钥匙，你将无法进入公寓，除非你住过
So why is there any door that has handles on both sides unless if it it's it's bi-directional if it is you can only exit by pulling and entering by pushing you should not have a handle and i don't any time that i grab or twist a handle or pull something and you have to push it drives me nuts only because i read that book and then it got pointed out to me and it's one of those things that now that it's been pointed out to me it drives me crazy i mean it's the the two taps for hot and cold not the end of the world not necessary but not the end of the world but the door you'll like the door is not well fitted to that frame and you'll you'll you'll notice you need you it's a great security feature if you have the key to my apartment you will not be able to get into the apartment unless you have lived in
这个公寓。是的，那是真的。第一次我拿钥匙，我向左扭，我向右扭，我当时想，我是不是拿错钥匙了？然后我想，不，只有一把钥匙。然后果然，我做了那种必须拉门之类的事情，但我只是稍微用力一点，它就开了。是的，你必须像往你这边拉，然后推。是的，只是因为门和门框之间的间隙不够。还有其他几件事。让我再次打断一下。我们回到沙发上。别担心。
this apartment yeah that is true the first time i took the t the the key i twisted it left i twisted it right and i was like did i grab the wrong key and i was like no there was only one key and then so sure enough i did one of the things where you have to pull on the door or whatever but then i just i just did it a little harder and it worked yeah you have to like pull towards you and then push yeah just because it's like the there's not enough clearance between the door and the door frame. There's a few other things. Let me interrupt again. We're getting back to the couch. Don't worry.
我吃完了我的苹果。我饿了。我今天没吃早餐也没吃午餐。我们现在在七分钟标记处。如果我加速两分钟，可能在五分钟标记处。什么？两分钟？如果我加速两分钟。什么？你会加速哪两分钟？
I finished my apple. I was hungry. I didn't have breakfast or lunch today. We're at the seven minute mark. Maybe the five minute mark if I had 10x, two minutes of that. What? Two minutes of that? if I 10x two minutes of that. What? What two minutes of that would you 10x?
但我，你知道吗？Bryce和我在一起的情况很少见，我记得我们在斯洛文尼亚公路旅行时录了大约八集。
But I'm, you know what? It's rare that Bryce and I are in the same location and that I said that I do recall that we recorded like eight episodes when we did our Slovenia road trip.
但我的意思是，如果你在七分钟标记处认为你快要结束了，如果我把所有这些都放进去，这将是一集45分钟的节目。所以它会更长。所以你会得到你通常的30、35分钟的内容，加上所有这些额外的内容，它将是一集45分钟的节目。所以它会更长。所以你会得到你通常的30、35分钟的内容，加上所有这些额外的东西。我们为喜欢听有趣内容和不那么有趣内容的听众保留了这些。
But my point being is if you're at the seven minute mark thinking you're about to drop, if I include all this in, it'll be a 45 minute episode. So it'll be longer. So you'll get your regular 30, 35 minutes of content and all this extra, it'll be a 45-minute episode. So it'll be longer. So you'll get your regular 30, 35 minutes of content and all this extra stuff. We're keeping in for the listener that likes to hear the interesting stuff and the less interesting stuff.
或者我应该说科技内容和非科技内容？回到沙发。我打算，尽管我喜欢我们的闲聊，我们要快速讲完这个沙发故事，因为然后我要对你大喊大叫关于分组操作的事。我们要谈谈，我们要谈谈，所以我有一个沙发商，嗯，他，哦，这就是让我想起它的原因，因为你已经有了家具或胡桃木专家，还是这都是同一个人？你有多少人？我觉得我以前讲过沙发商的故事，但你也告诉我你有一个室内设计师。是的，是的，好吧，那么沙发商回答这个问题，你有多少人
Or should I say the tech stuff and the non-tech stuff? Back to the coach. I'm going to, as much as i love our chit chat we're gonna do this couch story real quick because then i'm gonna yell at you about grouping operations right we're gonna talk about we're gonna talk about so i have a couch guy um he is oh that's what made me think of it because you already had uh a furniture or like walnut person or is this all the same how many people how many people do you have i feel like i've told the couch guy story before you all but you you also told me you had an interior decorator yeah yeah okay yeah so how good the couch answer the question how many people do you have that are
负责任何形式的家具或公寓装饰？我想真的只有设计师和沙发商。所以我有一个沙发商。他的名字叫Hans。他在伯克利有一撇很棒的胡子。我想他们叫
responsible for any form of furnishing or apartment decorating stuff i think it's really just in the the the decorator and the couch guy. So I have a couch guy. His name is Hans. He has a great freaking mustache in Berkeley. I think they're called
Alpha Designs Berkeley。所以他设计了我最后两个沙发，他会设计我拥有的每一个沙发，直到我死。你说的设计是什么意思？
Alpha Designs Berkeley. So he's designed my last two couches and he will design every couch that I own until I die. What do you mean design?
这是一个定制沙发？这是一个定制的、量身定做的沙发。哦，天哪。当我说是定制的时候，大多数人会说，哦，你是说设计这个，这是一个定制沙发，这是一个定制沙发，当我说是定制的时候，大多数人会说，哦，你是说他挑选了面料？不，这个沙发的每一个尺寸都是特别挑选的。所以我们被允许问这个沙发花了多少钱吗？它出奇地，出奇地实惠。那是什么意思？我们列出这个价格会疏远我们的听众吗？我的意思是，我想是5000美元，我想你可以在沙发上花更多钱。
This is a custom made couch? This is a custom made bespoke couch. Oh my goodness. And when I say custom made, most people are like, oh, you mean design this is a custom-made couch this is a custom-made couch and when you when i say custom-made people most people like oh you mean he like picked the fabric no every dimension of this couch was like specifically um selected so i are we allowed to ask how much this coach cost then it was surprisingly surprisingly affordable what does that mean are we gonna alienate our listeners by listing this price? I mean, I think it was $5,000, and I think you can spend a lot more on a couch.
如果你买真皮沙发，你可以花10000或15000美元。事实上，这是一个在美国制造的定制沙发，我认为这是一个相当不错的价格。所以你愿意把它留在节目里？因为对我来说，这听起来比我拥有的任何沙发都贵5倍。所以如果你对沙发有任何了解，你就会知道那就像……显然Connor不知道。那就像沙发的中间档次。作为参考，伊姆斯椅，它不是沙发，
If you're buying a leather couch, you can spend $10,000 or $15,000. The fact that this is a bespoke couch that was made in America, I think it's a pretty good price. So you're comfortable with leaving that in the episode? Because to me, that sounds like 5X more than any coach I've owned. So if you know anything about couches, you'll know that that's like... Which clearly Connor does not. That's like mid-range for couches. Like as a point of reference, the Eames chair, which is not a couch,
但它是一款带有脚凳的标志性躺椅。而且它是真皮的，不可否认，所以更贵。但像伊姆斯椅大约要7000到8000美元。那大概是椅子最高端的了。那只是我脑海中唯一知道价格的其他坐具。好吧，好吧，所以就是这样，各位，5000美元的定制沙发，所以没那么贵。所以Hans设计了我的第一个沙发，当我开始在NVIDIA工作，搬到圣克拉拉时，因为我开车经过他在伯克利的店，
but is an iconic recliner chair with a futon. And it's leather, admittedly, so it's more expensive. But like an Eames chair will run you like $7,000 to $8,000. And that's like probably like the highest end of like chairs. That's just like the only other piece of sitting furniture whose uh price i know at the top of my head all right all right so there you go folks five thousand dollar bespoke coach so not that expensive so i hans designed my first couch when i um started at nvidia and i moved down to uh uh to santa clara um because i'd driven back past his store in Berkeley,
大概十几次。我一直想进去。然后当我得到NVIDIA的工作时，他们给了我那笔不错的入职奖金。我想，你知道吗？我要进去从这个人那里买个沙发。我进去为我定制了一个沙发。
like a dozen times. And I'd always wanted to go in. And then when I got the job in NVIDIA, they gave me that nice starting bonus. I'm like, you know what? I'm going to go in and buy a couch from this man. I went in custom designed a couch for me.
沙发有一个方面我说，我想要这个。他告诉我我错了。它是一个像这样的部分，有一个你一直在睡觉的躺椅，然后它有一个常规的沙发主体，像两块。它有点像L型。但是不像这个沙发，我在这一侧放了一个扶手，
And there was one aspect of the couch where I said, I wanted this. And he told me I was wrong. And it was, it was a, a section like this where it had a lounger where you've been sleeping. Um, and then it had like a regular, like couch body, like two pieces. It was sort of L shaped. Um, but unlike this couch, I put an arm both on this,
这一侧，但背面也包围了。在那边，在大躺椅的末端有一个扶手。现在，躺椅部分很棒，因为我可以在看电视时躺下，你知道，睡着，因为我倾向于在看电视时睡着，这很棒，很舒服。然而，因为我在躺椅末端放了扶手，它刚好够我躺下，
the, this side here, but also the back wrapped around. And there was an arm on that side there, on the end of the big lounger piece. Now, the lounger piece was great because I could lie down while I was watching TV and, you know, fall asleep, because I tend to fall asleep while I'm watching TV, which is wonderful, nice and cozy. However, because I put the arm on the end of the Shea Lounge, it was just like, just large enough for me to lie down,
但我的脚会勉强碰到扶手。所以它不会是100%舒服。我必须拿掉靠背枕头，以一种非常特定的方式坐着，才能真正放松并躺在沙发的那个部分。Hans在我要求他在躺椅末端放扶手时告诉过我，他问我确定吗？我说，是的，这就是我想要的。但Hans知道，因为他是沙发巫师，他知道我不应该做那个决定，因为他知道人们喜欢躺在他们的躺椅上。所以总之，那是第一个沙发，她的名字叫Bertha，我以为我选的面料会更……等等，那不是我们现在坐的沙发？不，不，我们要讲那个，那是一个5000美元的沙发。不，不，那是像一个
but then my feet would just barely be pressing up against the arm. And so it wouldn't be like 100% comfortable. I would have to take off the back pillow and like sit in a very specific way to be able to like really just relax and lie on on on that part of the couch and and Hans had told me like when I'd asked him to put the arm on the end of the Shea Lounge he'd been like are you sure and I was like yeah that's exactly what I want but but Hans knew because he is a couch wizard he knew that I shouldn't have made that decision because he knew that people like to lie down in their shade their shade lounge so anyways that was couch number one her name was bertha and i thought the fabric that i picked was going to be more wait that wasn't the coach we're sitting on right now no no we're gonna get that that was a 5 000 coach no no that was like a
我想我为那个沙发付了大约1500到2000美元，2000美元。但那个是我在硅谷用了3到4年的沙发，她的名字叫Bertha。我以为她的面料会更像银蓝色，但结果它真的更接近绿色。
i think i paid like 1500 to 2000 for that $2,000 for that couch but that one was my couch in Silicon Valley for like 3 or 4 years her name was Bertha I thought that her fabric was going to be more of like a silvery blue but it turned out it was really kind of closer to a green
那是我的错，很棒的沙发，但它对这个公寓来说太大了，因为这是100英寸，我想Bertha大概有120英寸，所以空间勉强够。从这个沙发的末端到我的餐桌这里其实只有三英尺。我的，你管这些叫什么？我的意思是，当它们断开时，它们被称为岛台，但你的连接在墙上。是的，从厨房岛台。
that's on me great couch but it was too big for this apartment um because it was this is uh 100 inches um and i think it bertha was like 120 inches and so there's there is just barely enough room it's actually three feet from the end of this couch to the start of my kitchen table here. My like, what do you call these? I mean, when they're disconnected, they're called islands, but yours is connected to the wall. Yeah, from the kitchen island.
我们叫它厨房岛台。所以它是三英尺的原因是因为我特别，你知道，我特别把这个沙发建成最大空间，只留出三英尺。因为三英尺通常是你想要在任何家具和墙壁之间留出的空间。如果你想要三英尺的间隙，那足够人们走动了。所以，是的，Bertha太大了。所以我试着像个正常人一样买沙发。我去商店，看了沙发。我花了大约四天时间才找到这个公寓。
Let's call it the kitchen island. And so the reason that it's three feet is because I specifically, you know, I specifically built this couch to be the maximum amount of space that it could be leaving just three feet there. Because three feet is usually the amount of space that you want in between, you know, any piece of furniture and a wall. If you want like three feet of clearance, that's enough space for people to move. So, yeah, Bertha was too big. So I tried to buy a couch, like a regular human being. Like I went to stores, I looked at couches. It actually, it took me like four days to find this apartment.
然后我花了大约八天时间才为这个公寓找到沙发。所以，我找到了一个我想我会喜欢的沙发。它来自，我不记得哪里了，EQ3之类的。其他沙发，但它有多个独立的坐垫。所以它让躺下变得有点困难。但我终于找到了一个我还可以的，订购了它。我回到加州打包我的东西，搬到纽约。而且，那是我的生日，
Um, and then it took me like eight days to find the couch for this apartment. And, um, so I, I found a couch that I thought I was going to like. It was from, I don't remember where, EQ3 or something like that. Some other couch, but it had like multiple separate cushions. So it sort of made it like hard to lie down on. But I finally found one that I was like somewhat okay with ordered it. I went back to California to pack up my stuff, to move to New York. And, uh, it was my birthday and
我要去优胜美地过生日，去徒步旅行。我到了优胜美地，那是，那是去徒步旅行的前一天晚上。我在酒店，我当时想，我他妈讨厌我刚买的这个沙发，它完全错了，它不会足够舒服，它不是我脑海中完美的沙发。而且我知道Hans并不真的喜欢这个，这个家伙他建造的沙发只服务于湾区，这就是为什么我从未考虑过让他为我建造第二个沙发。但我当时太，我找沙发找了一个多星期，一直没成功，最后订了东西，然后决定我讨厌它。所以那天晚上在优胜美地，我打电话给那家我刚订购沙发的公司，取消了订单。然后我，不，它一定是
I was going to Yosemite for my birthday, um, to go on a hike. And, uh, I get to Yosemite and I'm, it's, it's like the evening before I'm going to go on my hike. And I, I'm at the hotel and I'm it's it's like the evening before I'm going to go on my hike and I I'm at the hotel and I'm just like I fucking hate this couch that I just bought it's it's just it's all wrong it's not going to be comfortable enough it is not the perfect like couch that I have in my head um and uh and I knew that like Hans didn't really like this this guy he built couches sort of only served the bay area um and that's that's why i'd never considered like having him build a second couch for me but i was just so i like i'd been searching for a couch for like more than a week and had just been unsuccessful and finally ordered something then decided i hated it um and so there, that night in Yosemite, I called up the company who I just ordered a couch from, canceled that order. And then I, no, it must have
一定是徒步旅行后我才做出的决定。因为我打电话给Hans，我记得我告诉Hans，嘿Hans，我有沙发紧急情况。我今天在优胜美地。我明天开车回湾区。我可以明天早上出现在你的店里，或者也许是，也许是像我开车回来的那天，但我基本上是说，我有沙发紧急情况。我可以从你这里订一个沙发吗？然后你能想办法把沙发从加州运到纽约吗？他说，我会想出一个计划。所以我进去，我们一起设计了这个沙发。它的工作方式是他有一些参考设计，你可以从那里开始。然后你可以像你想要的那样定制它们。
been, it must have been after the hike that I made this decision. Cause I called up Hans and I remember telling Hans, Hey Hans, I have a couch emergency. I'm in Yosemite today. I'm driving back to, uh, to the Bay area tomorrow. I can, I can be in your, uh, uh, in your shop like tomorrow morning, or maybe it was, maybe it was like the, the, the day that I drove back, but I was basically like, I have a couch emergency. Like, can I order a couch from you? And then can you figure out how to get the couch from California to New York? And he's like, I will, I will come up with a plan for that. So I went in and we worked to design this couch. And the way it works is he has some like reference designs that you can start with. And then you can like customize them pretty much however you want
像这个，这个的参考设计，它有一个我不喜欢的接缝，所以我说我们不做那个。而且像这个扶手的高度，我特别挑选了它会有多高，关于那个有很多来回讨论。但主要的事情是这个躺椅的长度，我不记得是多少英寸了。我想是89。不，不，不，不。它本来是89。所以最初它短得多，但我想要它足够长以便躺下。但我告诉他，好吧，让我们把它做成92英寸。他说，好吧，如果你做成92英寸，它会更贵，因为那比原始参考设计多了30英寸的延伸，我们可以做，但如果你把它保持在30英寸以下，你会省下像
like this, the reference design for this one, it had like a little seam here that i didn't like so i was like we're not doing that um and like the specific height of this like i specifically picked how high this arm was going to be there's a lot of back and forth about that um but the major thing was the length of this shade lounge um which i don't remember how many inches it was. I think it's like 89. No, no, no, no. It was going to be 89. So originally it was much shorter, but I wanted to be long enough to lie down on. But I told him like, all right, let's make it 92 inches. And he's like, all right, if you make it 92 though, it's going to be more expensive because that's more than a 30 inch extension from the original reference design and we can do it but if you keep it under 30 inches you'll save like
比如说300美元。所以最初我想，好吧，我就保持89英寸。然后我回家，又想了想，我想，你知道，只有三英寸，但当我设计这个并为我的身体长度测量这个时，我确定我需要那额外的三英寸。所以我打电话给他，我说，伙计，我想要它92英寸。我不在乎它是否多花300美元。总之，这就是这个沙发的故事。它里面有羽绒和记忆海绵芯。所以它非常舒服。Ramana起初不相信这个沙发，她觉得它太软了，但她后来成了沙发皈依者。
let's say it's like 300 bucks um and so originally i'm like all right i'll just keep it as 89 and then i went home and i thought some more about it and i was like you know it's only three inches but uh like when i when i designed this out and measured this for like my body length, like I determined that I needed those three extra inches. So I call him up and I'm like, dude, I want it to be 92 inches. I don't care if it costs $300 more. And, um, and yeah, that's the story of this couch. It's got like, uh, down inside with like a memory foam core. So it's very comfortable. Ramana wasn't a believer in the couch at first she thought it was too soft but uh she has since become a couch convert
总之，我现在可以大喊大叫关于分组操作了吗？是的，你只需要给我60秒。所以我会说，各位，我们在这里真正要做的是，我会保留我的60秒，我们开始播客。你正在听这个。这就像播客的前几分钟。在这个45分钟的播客结束时，会有15分钟关于Bryce的公寓，以及对他设计两个定制沙发所付出的努力的不短描述。因为我其实觉得这很有趣。原因大概是一天前，我不会……
anyways can i now yell about grouping operations yeah you just got to give me uh 60 seconds so i will say folks that uh what we're really going to do here is I will leave my 60 seconds in and we're starting the podcast. You're listening to this. This is like the first couple minutes of the podcast. At the end of this 45-minute podcast, there's going to be 15 minutes about Bryce's apartment and a not short description of the effort that went into designing both of his custom couches. Because I actually found it interesting. And the reason is like probably a day ago, I wouldn't have...
而且可能还会有第三个沙发。绝对的。我们会在你未来设计它时谈论它，因为一天前，我不会……不，不，不。我现在就解释。不，不，不，不。
And there will probably have to be a third couch too. Absolutely. And we will talk about that when you design that in the future now because a day ago, I wouldn't... No, no, no. I'm going to explain right now. No, no, no, no.
这个沙发是专门为这个公寓设计的，这个沙发能放进另一个公寓的可能性很低。所以很有可能当我们搬到新公寓时，这个东西会找到一个新家。我们只需要再设计一个。好吧。但下一个的设计会在未来的剧集中出现。但我说一天前我不会关心是因为我不认为自己。我关心算法和棋盘游戏之类的东西，但室内设计之类的，我可能
This couch was specifically designed for this apartment and the chances that this couch will fit in another apartment, pretty low. So chances are this thing is going to find a new home when we move to a new apartment. And we'll just have to design another one. All right. But the design of the next one will come up in a future episode. But the reason that I'm saying that a day ago I wouldn't have cared is because I don't really consider myself. Like I care about algorithms and like board games and stuff, but like interior design and whatnot, like I could
关心，我字面上把，嗯，你管它们叫什么？就像你在文具店买的海报纸板。然后我只是在上面写东西，把那些东西挂在墙上。我女朋友绝对讨厌它。而且，它们可能已经不在那里了。总之，重点是，在沙发上睡了一晚并看了电视后，我意识到，是的，我错过了生活，不是以一种微小的方式，而是以一种重大的方式。因为当你和两个人坐在沙发上时，如果你想躺下怎么办？但如果你只有一个常规的，我们还没真正提到它，但这是一个L型沙发，有常规沙发部分，然后是Bryce提到的躺椅部分，这给了你能力，如果你有多个人，你只想并排坐着
care, like I put literally the, um, what do you call them? Like poster cardboards that you buy at the dollar store. And then I just write stuff on them and I hang that stuff up on my wall. My girlfriend absolutely hates it. And, uh, I'm, they may not be there anymore anyways the point being is that after having slept on this couch for one night and having the tv i've realized that like yeah i'm missing out on life not in a minor way but in like a major way because when you're sitting on the couch with like two people what if you want to lie down but if you've just got a regular like we haven't really mentioned it but this is like an l-shaped couch with like the regular couch part and then the chaise lounge part that bryce referred to and that gives you the ability if you got multiple people and you just want to sit side by side
或者如果你想非常舒服地躺下，你不必侧身，也不用担心找枕头来支撑你的脖子。也许这对某类成年人来说是基本知识。但我不在那类成年人中。不，不是。不只是你。只是很少有人像我一样深入思考过沙发。但睡在这个沙发上让我意识到，我以前对待沙发的方式是错的。这就是为什么一天前我不会
or if you want to lay down like very comfortably you don't have to then go on your side and worry about getting a pillow to prop your neck up. And maybe this is like basic knowledge for like a certain category of adults. But I am not in that category of adults. No, it's not. It's not just you. It's just that like there are very few people who have thought as deeply about couches as I have thought about couches. But just having slept on this couch has made me realize that like I'm doing couches wrong. And that's why a day ago i wouldn't have
关心那个沙发解释，我会说谁在乎啊Bryce。但睡在这个沙发上，在脑海中把它与我公寓里的沙发进行比较，你的沙发有多个坐垫吗？它在坐位处有三个坐垫，然后有三个靠背坐垫。是的，它只是，我会在描述中放链接，这是我姐姐搬到卡尔加里时给我的宜家沙发。它们简直是我生活的克星，因为我们每个位置都有一个单独的坐垫，这让躺在沙发上变得超级不舒服，这简直是沙发行业的骗局。它的理论是，哦，如果你有多个坐垫，每个人
cared about that couch explanation i would have been like who cares bryce but having slept on this couch comparing it mentally to my coach in my head or in my apartment does your couch have multiple cushions it has three cushions in the seated spot and then three sort of back cushions yes it's just it's just i'll link it in the description it's a hand-me-down ikea couch for my sister when she moved to calgary are like the bane of my existence like we have like an individual cushion for like each individual spot because it makes it super uncomfortable to lie down on the couch and it's just like a scam by the couch industry the the theory of it is oh well if you have multiple cushions and each person
一个人坐下不会影响另一个人坐下。但人们坐在沙发上，像椅子一样并排坐着的情况有多常见？没人那样做。没人那样做。他们有小坐垫而不是一个大坐垫的原因，你能猜到吗Connor？它更容易运输，而且制造更便宜。是的，制造更小的坐垫更便宜，而不是一个更大的坐垫。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，这和窗户上的玻璃板是一样的，对吧？更大的那些要贵得多，
like one person sitting down doesn't infect the other person sitting down but like how common is it for people to sit on a couch where they're like all seated seated next to each other just sitting there like it's a chair nobody does that nobody does that the reason that they have the small the smaller cushions uh instead of one big larger cushion can you guess connor it's easier to ship it's easier to ship and it's cheaper to make yeah it's cheaper to make smaller uh cushions um and uh instead of one bigger cushion yep yeah that makes sense i mean it's the same thing with the like glass panes and windows right like the bigger ones are way more
因为它们更难运输，也更难制造。而如果你买一堆更小的，你可以堆叠它们，占用更少的空间等等。我的沙发没有那么多坐垫，它有一个像床垫一样的东西，躺椅的那个基本上是一个单人床垫的大小，然后另一块也有一个。是的，是的，但它是，你知道吗各位，好吧，又过了四分钟，所以真正会发生的是，我们将在60秒内开始谈论算法。这可能是一集50分钟到一小时的节目。我不会编辑，就做一集沙发节目吧伙计。我不认为，人们真的想要一集沙发节目吗？伙计。我不认为。人们真的想要一集沙发节目吗？我想他们想要。我们应该吗？
expensive because they're way harder to ship and they're way harder to manufacture um whereas if you get a bunch of smaller ones like this is wait you can stack them it takes less space etc my couch doesn't so much have cushions it has like a mattress like the uh the the one for the shea lounge is basically the size of like a single mattress um and then there's one for the other piece too yeah yeah but it's it is uh you know what folks all right once again it's been like four minutes so here's what's really gonna happen we're gonna start talking about algorithms in in 60 seconds this is probably gonna be like a 50 minute to an hour minute an hour episode i'm not gonna edit just do a couch episode man i don't think do people really want a couch episode they man. I don't think. Do people really want a couch episode? I think they do. Should we?
我想。我们应该发布一整集关于沙发的节目吗？我觉得应该有一集关于沙发的。你知道吗，各位？去他的。我们还有六分钟的沙发内容。天哪，我们能聊聊沙发床吗？好吧。
I think. Should we just release a whole episode on couches? I think there should be a couch episode. You know what, folks? Screw it. We got six more minutes of couch content. God, and can we talk about sleeper sofas? All right.
所以等等，等等，等等。你知道，再一次，听众们，这是同样的事情。这次我很投入，而那一集，是关于什么的？不是VIN码。郑重声明，我准备好没有任何介绍就直接跳进去谈论分组操作并切入正题。我准备好了。无论我们是否要在播客上谈论，我都准备好做这件事，因为我们只是在谈论工作上的事情。我想在这个话题上和你互动，但你是那个想要做
So wait, wait, wait, wait, though. You know, once again, listeners, this is the same thing. I'm engaged this time, whereas that episode, what was it about? Not the VIN numbers. For the record, I was ready to just jump in without any intro and talk about grouping operations and be on topic. I was ready to go. I was ready to do this regardless of whether we were going to talk on a podcast or not because we were just talking about work stuff. And I wanted to engage with you on this topic. we were going to talk on a podcast or not because we were just talking about work stuff and i i wanted to engage with you on this topic but you were the one who wanted to do the wanted to do
那些花絮的人，然后你有了沙发故事。我不知道这是否就是那样发生的，我想我提到了什么，然后你想要谈论沙发，但因为我的兴趣，它膨胀成了更多东西。但就像我在谈论沙发床或不管那是什么东西之前要说的，类似于信用卡号码那一集，我以为那会失败，我以为那会失败。各位，我们征求了反馈，绝大多数反馈都是积极的，有些人说这是迄今为止最有趣的一集。请再次查看节目说明中的GitHub讨论链接，或在Twitter上留下反馈。我不保证这会是一集好节目。
the fluff and then you got the couch story i don't know exactly if that's how it went down i think i mentioned something then you wanted to talk about the couches but then because of my interest it's ballooned into something more but uh like i was about to say before we talk about sleepers or whatever the heck those are similar to what was it the credit card number episode i thought that was gonna flop i thought it was gonna flop folks we asked for feedback and overwhelmingly every single piece of feedback was uh was mostly positive and some of them said it was the funniest episode yet uh please once again link in the show notes to a GitHub discussion or leave feedback on Twitter. I'm not promising that this is going to be a good episode.
我只是想知道，你们会更喜欢我们直接剪掉这些内容吗？或者我打算做的是直接发布未编辑的版本。因为那样不需要任何额外的时间。我只是，不管怎样，把它拼接在一起，这为我节省了一个小时。
I just like to know, do, would you have preferred us to just cut this stuff? Or what I was going to do is just post fix it unedited. Cause then it doesn't take any extra time. I just, whatever, splice it together and it saves me an extra hour.
让我们知道。你喜欢吗？我迫不及待地想谈谈沙发床。而且，让我们检查一下时间戳。我们有25分20秒。所以我们有五分钟的时间把它保持在紧凑的30分钟内。开始吧，沙发床。首先，什么是沙发床？
And let us know. Do you like it? I'm rearing to talk about sleeper sofas. And also, let's just check the timestamp. We got 25 minutes and 20 seconds. So we got five minutes to keep this into a tight 30. Go, sleepers. First of all, what is a sleeper?
所以沙发床是一种能以某种方式变成床的沙发。通常下面有一个床垫。哦，拉出式沙发。是的，拉出式沙发，当然。这是外行人的叫法。沙发座下面有一个床垫，可以拉出来。现在，事情是这样的。在我看来，沙发床有一个深刻的教训。这里有一个深刻的人生教训。
So a sleeper sofa is a sofa that somehow transforms into a bed. Usually there's like a mattress that's underneath. Oh, a pull-out sofa. Yeah, a pull-out sofa, sure. It's what the lay people call it. There's a mattress that's underneath the seat of the couch and it pulls out. Now, here's the thing. And there is a deep lesson in my opinion of sleeper sofas. A deep life lesson here.
我花了一些时间睡在沙发床上。我的祖父母，他们实际上在家具行业工作，有趣的事实，Bryce的祖父母是家具销售员和室内设计师。但尽管是家具销售员，他们有一个他妈的糟糕的沙发床，世界上最不舒服的一个。然后出于某种原因，
And I have spent some time sleeping on sleeper sofas. My grandparents, who actually worked in the furniture industry, fun fact, Bryce's grandparents were furniture salespeople and interior decorators. But despite being furniture salesmen, they have a fucking terrible sleeper sofa, the most uncomfortable one in the world. And then for some reason,
我阿姨买了同一个。就像家里每个人一样，这个沙发床太糟糕了，当人们去和祖父母住时，第一，人们不再和他们住了，因为它太不舒服了。但第二，我们会直接把沙发床里的床垫拿出来，
my aunt bought the same one. Like everybody in the family, this sleeper sofa is so bad that when people go over to stay with the, one, people stopped staying with my grandparents because it was so uncomfortable. But two, we would just take the mattress out of the sleeper sofa
直接放在地上，因为那样更舒服。但为什么沙发床这么烂？嗯，因为它们往往既做不好床，也做不好沙发。它们试图成为两样东西，但两者都做得平庸。我想要一个我能睡的沙发，但我特别避免了任何你可以称为沙发床的东西。我只是想要一个大沙发，有一个像这个躺椅一样的空间，不仅适合一个人，而且两个人实际上可以并排睡在那里。
and just put it on the ground because that'd be more comfortable. But so why does sleeper sofas suck? Well, because they tend to be bad at being a bed and bad at being a sofa. Like they're trying to be two things and they do both of them in a mediocre fashion. And like I wanted a sofa that I'd be able to sleep on, but specifically I avoided anything that you could call a sleeper sofa. I just wanted a big couch that would have a space like this Shea Lounge that would be suitable for not only one, but two people can actually sleep on there side by side.
然后把它放在地上，因为那样会更舒服。那么为什么沙发床很糟糕呢？嗯，因为它们往往既做不好床，也做不好沙发。就像它们试图兼顾两样东西，结果两样都做得平庸。我想要一张我能睡在上面的沙发，但我特意避开了任何可以被称为沙发床的东西。我只是想要一张大沙发，它有一个像贵妃榻这样的空间，不仅适合一个人，而且两个人实际上可以并排睡在上面。
But because it's not a sleeper sofa, because it's not trying to be two different things, it is far more successful and a lot less bulky. Although one design problem with this couch, which I did not know I was going to have a dog when we got this couch, because I got this couch prior to the girlfriend and the dog, there is space underneath the couch. It does not have feet or a runner that goes to the floor.
但因为它不是沙发床，因为它不需要兼顾两种功能，所以它非常成功，而且体积小得多。不过这款沙发有一个设计问题，我在买沙发时并不知道后来会养狗，因为我是在有女朋友和狗之前买的，沙发下面有空间。它没有支撑到地面的底座或滑轨。
And the next couch will have some sort of runner a runner that goes to the floor. And the next couch will have some sort of runners. And then he goes to the floor. Can you guess why? Cause the dog likes to hide under the coach. The dog likes to hide her balls under the couch. Cause the dog only likes to play. If she's, if she has our attention playing,
下一张沙发一定要有某种滑轨，一种能延伸到地面的滑轨。下一张沙发一定要有某种滑轨。然后它会延伸到地面。你能猜到为什么吗？因为狗狗喜欢躲在沙发下面。狗狗喜欢把球藏在沙发下面。因为狗狗只喜欢玩耍。如果她是，如果她有我们的关注在玩耍，
playing on her own, that's no fun for her. She wants our attention. And so she, she has our attention. Playing on her own, that's no fun for her. She wants our attention. And so she has, you know, the first few times that she lost the ball under the couch, she would whine and complain. She'd be like, hey, come help me. And we'd come help her.
她自己玩的话，对她来说没意思。她想要我们的关注。所以她，她有我们的关注。她自己玩的话，对她来说没意思。她想要我们的关注。所以她，你知道，最初几次她把球弄到沙发底下时，她会呜呜叫着抱怨。她会像是在说，嘿，快来帮帮我。然后我们就会去帮她。
And then she'd be like, aha, I have learned a new trick. If I just put the ball underneath the couch or if I put the ball in between the couch and the window where I can't reach it and then I whine and look pathetic, then the humans will come and retrieve it for me. So the next apartment is going to have no spaces where the dog can lose the ball. Look at that. Fantastic. Yeah. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening.
然后她就会想，啊哈，我学会了一个新把戏。如果我把球塞到沙发底下，或者塞到沙发和窗户之间我够不到的地方，然后我呜呜叫着装可怜，人类就会过来帮我捡回来。所以下一套公寓绝对不能有任何会让狗把球弄丢的空间。你看，太棒了。是的，请务必查看播客应用或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上的节目笔记，获取我们今天提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quality. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你们喜欢，祝你们有愉快的一天。低质量，高质量。这是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。